it's godzilla
well friends it is time to answer the
age-old question who would win a fight
between a giant ape and a building-sized
lizard we're breaking down everything we
know about godzilla versus kong
right now on the ketchup on march 31st
godzilla vs kong will hit theaters and
hbo max simultaneously and we
are here for it the fourth film in
legendary's monster verse
gbk as i'm calling it is a sequel to
2014's godzilla as well as godzilla king
of the monsters and
kong skull island it also marks the
first time these two larger-than-life
leviathans have shared a screen since
1962's king kong vs godzilla
legendary is armed blair witch director
adam wingard with a reported 200 million
dollar budget and after seeing the
trailer we think he put it to good use
godzilla vs kong looks like both an epic
brawl that'll have audiences cheering
for the giant lizard and ape and
a nail-biting disaster film for the
humans unlucky enough to be sitting
ringside to the fight which
this time around includes alexander
skarsgard rebecca hall
brian tyree henry and returning cast
members millie bobby brown and kyle
chandler the only question now is who do
you have your money on
kong bows to no one updating the
franchise for a new generation of super
fans
legendaries kaiju are now called titans
the godzilla legacy meanwhile sheds its
original thesis warning about nuclear
capabilities during war
for a more relevant message about global
warming and eco-terrorism
see in this version of godzilla the
radiation emitted by the titans is
actually healing the planet and godzilla
while not exactly a pro-humanist
is definitely working to restore balance
in the ecosystem
also there are aliens as introduced by
the three-headed space dragon godora and
king of the monsters
does that explain the tiny spaceship
next to kong's inverted head in the new
trailer or explain where he got his new
weapon
only time will tell but speaking of kong
is that a monkey we actually don't know
that much about what kong has been up to
since we last saw him in the 1970s in
the events of kong skull island
i guess he's just hanging out making
friends with small orphan girls and
chillaxing if people still use that word
but you know
giant gorilla stuff we do know that
monarch the government agency working to
understand the titans and godzilla king
of the monsters was already a shadowy
government organization decades prior
and actively searching for kong we also
know from the cave painting scene in the
closing credits of the film that kong
has tangled with kaiju before
including mothra rodan king ghidorah and
yes godzilla himself
most importantly though we can see that
kong had a bit of a growth spurt since
the last time we saw him going from
roughly 100 feet tall
somewhere in the neighborhood of 300
feet in this film supposedly that is
because kong was just an adolescent the
last time we saw him and i mean come on
they gotta make it a fair fight
let me list all the ways you're gonna
die so who will win in a fight between
these two mega predators
well the last time these two met in
1962's king kong vs godzilla
it looks like godzilla had the upper
hand i mean after all he is the king of
the monsters
king kong on the other hand is just a
very large gorilla who gets sleepy if he
eats too many red berries i know the
feeling
after kong floats to the top of mount
fuji on a bunch of balloons yup you
heard that right he is struck by
lightning develops his own superpowers
and pummels the amphibious lizard back
into the ocean only to resurface alone
so kong wins and it's the end or is it
hint it is definitely not the end so
does that mean we can expect to see the
king of monsters bow down to the king of
kongs yet again
it's impossible to guess our guess is
actually that the true villains are
probably not either monster since they
both have vested interest in protecting
at least some of humanity not to mention
future franchise
installments
but friends it is time for us to kick it
over to you now what are your theories
around godzilla vs
kong let us know in the comment section
also let us know who you think is going
to win this epic brawl
and of course if you want more movie and
streaming news head on over to ron
tomatoes.com
also be sure to check out our show
verses for an even more in-depth
breakdown of godzilla and kong duking it
out on screen
and if you don't want to miss out on any
future episodes of this show be sure to
hit the subscribe button and
notification bell and as always we can't
thank you enough for watching the
ketchup
my name is az perez and we'll see you
next time bye
[Music]
you